[Music] you have 12 hours to commit one crime
and you're not going to get in trouble for it
what is it oh I'm going to oh I got to steal a
cool car you're going to steal a car yeah a cool
car like a really fast car like vroom vroom it's
zero to to 60 in A5 second I was hoping you were
going to kill somebody but that's a different
story for a different time it's Benny Veronica
someon Louise it's Teran Roxy we did it we missed
hands but we're talking about the birge watching
The Purge today apparently that's the premise
I've never seen this movie but I've heard it
referenced a thousand times because people
always ask that it's kind of a common first
date question what who's going on dates with what
who are these people just saying if you guys were
on the dates that I was on you would have been
asked the question about The Purge before and
you would know exactly what your answer already
was I would have ran out if you like everything
that's going on so far and you are excited about
this video leave a like a comment let us know how
cool you think we are especially cuz it's spooky
season yeah and don't forget to ring the bell ring
the bell I could have set you up better for that
one I knew you were going to come in with the bell
I just sometimes I can't wait I just like I got
to I Feel It In My Bones yeah and you guys can't
wait either to see more of us over on patreon
with a full length Reaction watch along where
you sink up with your own copy I didn't look
down at the shape for that yeah baby she's
got it down she's got it memorized yeah Greg and
John are over there and they cover several shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included are you ready to purge everything
that's gone wrong this year and jump into the
purge emotionally yeah but for the other stuff
not ready yet that'll be later at home by myself
very good let's watch The Purge cool [Music]
spooky music in a world where you can
decide who gets to live and die for
12 hours Terra stole a car yeah
I didn't ask Roxy what she would
do but I know she I guess she would
kill people okay unemployment's at
1% so this must have been filmed before 2022 right
and they were hoping that was going to be very low
crime when is this movie from they were like crime
is super low in 2022 and we're like yo homies that
was last year and crime was very [Laughter] high
oh okay Ethan Hawk didn't know he was in this also
found Foley or Hy or however you say her name
I like her too this is what happens during The
Purge the juxtoposition of these shots and this
music is yeah very so much if you just closed your
eyes you would think we were watching something
that you could watch with your grandparents yeah
the music's by Nathan Whitehead so you made a
choice here I like it I think I would have made
the obvious one and put like metal music over it
but this is way better system is working without a
hitch you are going to be locked in tight tonight
thank you sir all right Mr Faulk safe night James
office Sue yeah I took care of folk what do you
know do you hear anything you're number one Mr
sandon you got it sir congrats congratulations
to you too Susan you don't have to say that no
Susan it's a team win thank you okay all right
well safe night safe night Mr sand between this
and black phone is uh Ethan Hawk kind of a horror
horror guy now right beat from Northern Virginia
what's your Purge plan I'm going to hunt down
my BS what American streets will be running
r tonight is that why everyone's setting flowers
you getting one last walk in before lock down huh
all right nobody's bothering us tonight well
you have a safe night Mr Sanders which means
everyone's bothering them tonight do you think
this is a smart idea like the the the concept of
The Purge so that there's less crime year round
because you can just do it that one day with no
penalty not to make it political I feel like some
people would watch this and try to implement I'm
thinking it through it might be until the
annual Purge okay not 60 Minutes 62 minutes
but they set out the blue flowers to show their
support of it right we are inherently a violent
species Wars genocide murder the denial of our
true selves is the problem The Purge not only
contains social violence to a single evening
[Laughter] Purge that's what you would do all
night anytime I mess with somebody pillow
before say perge bump into people ooh Young
Love or is it lust probably lust I love you
oh nope it's love that's what she thinks girl
why because everyone says I love you it's used
and we need to find our own thing go like this
no do it it's our way to saying I love you that's
fing cute that is cute she doesn't want to do it
cuz she thinks look silly okay I love that she
did it I think my dad's home I'm sorry baby
got to get going I'm sorry and you have to get
home before lockdown why aren't you doing it all
right I bullied you
[Music] this movie is kind of quirky yeah
and it kind of feels like a home video the
way it's shot a little like I don't know that
it's there's a lot of shaky cam stuff going on
handhelds oh I have a new hobby Bing I made
way too many cookies Hi O cookies maybe she
poison them yeah why does this something seem off
yeah just what the hon needed more cookies right
they do she does not like her new addition you
built it's just amazing that house is sick you
know your husband sold a new security system
to almost every home in this community he's
about to tell her this neighborhood paid
for that new addition on your home it's
just good old neighborhood gossip nothing
to worry about I can't stand her I hope she
dies in The Purge one we're just going to
lock down watch some Purge events nothing
special that's what I would do that's what
I do on New Year's Eve lock it in watch it
on TV watch some Purge events like yeah
newscasters out recording it even though
it's not illegal it's so creepy what is
this POV the dog dude maybe it's a cat
Roxy you scared me to death it's just a drum is
it their you can't keep creeping up on me like
that Charlie oh security nice so quit playing
with Timmy and come help me set the table kid
up now why is he looking at his mom's legs
yeah that that angle is a little weird little
creeper I insted a night vision program and
I insulated his motor so you can barely hear
him and he can now play music to accompany
him on his missions terrible song I don't
like it that's really rude of you I mean you were
really dancing to it I don't know why I kind of D
it
Purge sorry I forgot to take my vitals earlier
by the way there's a slight deviation in my heart
rate but uh other than that nothing to worry
about what I that kid I didn't all sales are
final and I'm on top my division sold the most
upgraded security systems congratulations Dad
yay Ethan all right it's time for lock down
let's go what do you think they do go into
a bunker yeah they have to right in a basement
and then oh God Mr Sabian and Mr Babar are going
hunting that's daring fens are having a party
Grace said she wasn't having a party this year
well just thank God we weren't invited she's
nice but she's annoying agreed minus a nice
part she makes cookies though so do I at the
front if you brought cookies I'd like you more
R I bring cookies all the time but Greg doesn't
eat eat them except on the weekend so I'll bring
you cookies I eat them all right let's hit it
what are they hitting exactly like they they're
Lo okay what is it their whole house though oh
wow oh I guess it's all the windows or yeah is
the security system that he's selling to other
people this is like stainless steel walls coming
down it must be the the what he sells that's
intense this is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the annual
Purge weapons of class four and lower have
been authorized for use during The Purge wow
government officials of ranking 10 have been
granted immunity from The Purge and shall not
be harmed oh I was wondering if people try to
kill the president yeah murder will be legal and
murder police fire and Emergency Medical Services
will be unavailable until tomorrow morning at 7:00
a.m. when The Purge concludes blessed be our new
founding fathers and America Nation reborn what a
wild premise that's insane that's scary I thought
they were just going to like wander around and
like take stuff can I go now I would prefer to
be miserable in my room of course you may thank
you for being here who do you think's going to
die of the four of them the teenager girl first
allows people a release for all the hatred and
violence and aggression that they keep up inside
them if your mother and I were so inclined uh we
would participate because it works I kind of feel
him bro I really do and I'm like sitting in how
real this is right now going like holy tamolly
holy to I think it's holy Toledo I don't say that
Roxy Hide Away throwing
your her boyfriend okay how do he get in
stainless steel you just was there the whole
time obviously wanted to surprise you left so
I snuck in when you were eating baby you can't
be in here my dad will lose his mind if he sees
you here now come on aren't you happy to see me
can't leave now they're behind stainless
steel walls so is the purge really about
releasing aggression and containing violence
detractors often postulate this evening is
actually about the elimination of the poor
the needy the sick those unable to defend
themselves that's so I didn't even think about
that that the elite would go out they're going out
hunting they're killing the poor on the streets
to clean up the streets you and I are people
that we thought this was a good idea for I know
I I just thought of what Ethan Hawk was selling
and that's what I assumed like oh yeah you you
got rageed like go break a window and steal a I
don't know steal a candy bar only rich people can
do this dang that's why he said they're going out
hunting that's what I didn't understand I just
said that's crazy what's wrong with us terara
put us in in the lock us up PC [Laughter] prison
oh oh he's spying on his sister and he was into
his mom's leg the little boy's a creeper right
here we go oh my God oh my God I hate if he stops
and looks up his sister's skirt he no I came to
see your father what why it's time to straighten
this out he cannot forbid you from saying me he
thinks you're too old for me talking to him is
only going to make him more angry he's older than
her he looks younger D yeah he's gonna try to hurt
the dad came to see your father or maybe he's just
like oh this is the one night that your dad can't
leave and he has to talk to meist I think that's
what he was just implying just then but that
doesn't mean it's true criminalization of murder
for one night Purge sorry this is working this
is working this is wild I do think it would work
to lower the crime rates through through the year
right it just also doesn't like say that you
can't be her and you hate somebody from high
school and you're like I'm going to go kill her
now they sell it as like rich people killing
poor people but still it's it's wild I thought
I heard gunshots it's probably somebody just
firing off a few rounds before going hunting
I have a feeling the poor people are going
to get together and be like if they're going
to do this to us now we need to go like take
over Beverly Hills and kill them all and now
supposed to be seeing right now okay in the
corner what's he seeing this person run to
what that's across the street right okay
what's Happening Here help me someone
please help me oh no it's fake I feel
like that person doesn't need help and he
going to kill the little kid might try to
help him or something I just need to get some
safe anybody hear me like I won't hurt you no
kid somebody please just open the door for me
they're coming they're coming King somebody
please they going kill me oh my God come
here let's go this way come on oh no hurry
this little kid is going to be the demise
of everybody he doesn't get get it oh my
god oh no hurry oh no he's going to get killed my
God is he going to get okay
okay oh no the hell's going
on oh no what is going to happen commercial break
I know right what Mr sandon James he has it gone
Henry has a gun holy oh my go hen hen oh God
is Zoe I didn't hit Zoe she's Zoe where's the
other dude who is he why did you let him in our
home he was hurt he called for help no one was
helping we have no idea what this man is capable
of enough James he's gone he's not gone he's not
gone you're he's in the house Henry Henry why
did you try to shoot my father yeah exactly
like why aren't you like what in the actual F
dude like you had a gun he I'm confused why is
she is she in on it or is she like no way what
I'll go out there and I'm going to find Zoe Zoe
doesn't want to be found he didn't shoot at me
I I'll find her so I can go I can't let you go
with that man out there send the little robot
yeah exactly like that's the one time it would
be useful where is the Little Robot yeah where'd
you leave it kid Zoe this me oh dang is he dead
yeah I think so I think he's going to like grab
him oh no somebody's no check your surroundings
bro yeah like where's the daughter behind Charlie
you wait here I'm going to be right outside the
door he's definitely not going to wait there he
has a whole lir really that he wants to get back
to Mom I didn't know him was going to do that I
didn't know he was going to why would he do that
I don't understand why just give me a second okay
momy died he's dead he's dead mom mom Charlie come
oh God is he Charlie Sees the guy what Dad I'm
sorry where are you going girl okay zo where is
she she going there's the lack of communication
bro this family's got issues yeah I would grab
her arm and be like you are in this room you're
grounded oh is that annoying lady yeah they all
the people that are having party they're coming
to the house they're coming to the house because
there there their Community built the add-on and
not everybody had as good of a year as them whoa
is she okay is she is she she's not her I I
couldn't get her to come with me feel like
she didn't try to get her to come with you but all
leted slide oh my God tell them what is like what
are we going to do they all the same security
system so they know how they work exactly and
I'm like but what are they hoping to gain here
I'm like he sold you the system that's keeping
you safe and now you guys are like no maybe
they sent the guy into the house to dis to
[Music] get and then they have to be your
neighbors afterwards so awkward we want to
treat you fairly so listen closely we've gotten
gussed up in our most terrifying guyses as we
do every year but things took a turn our Target
escaped us and uh oh your neighbors informed us
that you the sandon have inexplicably given him
Sanctuary Mr Mrs the man you're Sheltering is
nothing but a dirty homeless Pig killing one of
us when we attempted to execute him tonight waa
you need to return him to us alive so that we
may Purge as we are entitled wow that is some
tough verbage this movie is [__] up you have
until our Provisions arrive Provisions which
will help us break into your elegant home if
you don't deliver him by the aforementioned
time we'll release the beast on him and on you
we can enter any home we want as wanting as our
will on this fine night wow that dialogue is is
great uh we don't want to kill our own also the
shot the angle on his face he's so menacing Purge
her in the background brilliant we thought it was
the neighbors but it's not wow that was very
very well done and the premise of this just
got so much more interesting splitting them
between the halves and the Have Nots and like
would you give a poor person up to save your
family if this was your Society disgusting
what an interesting so gross it also brings up
the tough like realization there are people like
that who are like we are entitled to kill this
person because they are less than what we think
the system it works 99% of the time it looks good
it's strong people stay away is it impenetrable no
nothing's impenetrable things like this are not
supposed to happen in our neighborhood ooh this
is a classist movie we're going to give them what
they want we have guns and he doesn't but they'll
kill him okay kid I like you now why should
he die it's Dr that's a but if you're a parent
tough call you just go well this Society is Fu up
bro and it's our society it's pushing them into
like it's you can't it's an impossible decision
either they all die or they send the one guy out
well it's not that though they don't know that
they're all going to die but they know if they
send him out he's going to die that they would
probably all die an elitist disgusting movie I
did not think that's what this was going to be I
thought it was going to be like fun horror movie
not like a question on around yeah exactly like
a question on the societal standards of you give
us the homeless man no will miss him when he's
gone please I just thought people were going to
be running around stealing stuff and we'd see it
I don't know we hear you're like us the halves oh
oh creepy found footage part two weird
it's not cuz it's their whatever cams
but it looks like that it really does maybe
they should kill them right yeah I guess they
could just kill all of those people and
keep the keep the guy who wasn't trying
to hurt anybody alive it's a harder
task but I got enough weapons for it
though why are the lights off I missed that I
don't they must have they must have lost yeah
oh this thing it doesn't make sense though
because then the the TVs are still on so
they still have power that's their backup
generator oh rich people [__] yeah is
right there tell him yeah but little kid's
trying to protect him can he talk out of
that thing nobody can listen remember when the
mom was talking to him and it plays music now
remember he showed that it can play songs yeah
terrible song you're so rude about my favorite
song like what it is he Morse coding oh
cuz he sees the tags smart yeah oh he's
a vet this movie knows how to get us
to like yeah to get your pull at the
strings is he showing him where to
hide where are
you fire him I'm like what the [__] is
this rich people [__] right it's super
uncomfortable themes that this is about
like poverty race yeah morals just like
in general it's just making you think
everything just very smart movie so far
oh oh gave him his lair it's so [__] up
that there are so many homeless veterans
yeah it's weird to highlight the class
system of people who want to go fight
for where you live and they don't they don't
have an opportunity to live very well once
they come back it's like we can give all the
money in the world to the military but not to
the members that fight for the country and
then come back with nowhere to live Dear Mr
sandon sorry to interrupt but I'd love to have
a word leave by your front door I just need a
moment good sir would you go yeah a cool shot
SLI going to W what there you are tell me why
haven't you delivered the filthy swine to me
yet are you protecting him no we can't find
him my son let him in but I support what occurs
here tonight 100% just give us the homeless P
you [__] what I don't condemn that kind of
behavior not civilized pleas keep in mind Mr
sandon he was my friend and you are not ha
who is this actor he's fing good he's very
good okay okay I don't know what's going on
there there are people outside I'll be okay
I have his gun I'm going to go hide in your
secret spot okay yep [Music] no another good
plot moment yeah who wrote this nice twist
it's great dialogue like I really love and
story they crushed it Purge are you getting
annoyed with it or no it's no I'm fine with
it knew it yeah cuz he's a veteran he's gonna
know we didn't do anything to you we don't
deserve this I didn't deserve this either Y
and I don't want to hurt any of you but I am
not dying tonight who's behind him yeah it's the
kid the kid came oh the mom mom the mom but she
can't shoot him she can't so take that gun away
from my daughter's head shoot it Mary shoot it
what the what happened I think he threw
the girl yeah he threw her but then
what [__] what what he shot [Music] him he
then asked for him delivered alive remember
and we have to tie him up and get him outside
and we're going to end this goddamn night it's
just so up like that they think his life is not as
important as right if they were smart they would
see the tags and say we could all fight together
you have the most skills in fighting military man
let's go kill these jerk offs outside but then
he puts his kids at risk I understand everybody's
motivation but this okay oh no she's not going to
be okay with it the tape and tape them in there
oh what oh you got to calm down he's going to
break this t press on his wound press
on his wounds just trying to protect my
family what calm down oh my
God me what oh my gosh stop
again oh oh my goodness like who will your
kids be though if they think that this is
acceptable behavior you meant like what
example are you guys setting right yeah
a terrible one look what we're doing
yeah yeah okay go Charlie Charlie baby
where'd you go oh no is he opening the doors
don't fing disarm this [__] again Charlie
you little no there there's no way cuz he
doesn't want to give the guy up yeah but
then that way he thinks I don't know sit
down sit down you hit your head are you
okay I am so sorry about Henry oh no the guy got
loose look at what you're doing nothing is ever
going to be okay again he is in a tough position
but you can't turn into a monster right you have
to do the right thing or you can't live with
yourself you should have just been like we have
to get rid of these people together so that you
don't die these are the [__] outside yep and
it's risky save your children take me outside
but give him the weapons that guy is too good
he's too good you better sew him up give him
all your weapons you guys messed up what what
is this oh it's the oh it's the equipment the
backup all right the arrival down oh this is
is terrifying oh my God they're going to that's
going to be five 10 seconds no longer you're not
you're not sending I have another idea okay
you take this gun all right you're going to
go hide in the basement and you're not going to
come out for anybody all right everybody gets a
gun now you have enough we're going to fight
yeah yeah yeah fight fight fight fight fight
take this y'all better get with it get with a
plan you're going to use a lot of rounds what
do I do you're going to over the other side of
the house yes you fine folk should know better
that piece of Filth that you are protecting
exists only to serve our need to purge release
the beast boys let the killing commence what
is the Beast that they keep referring to the
Beast I guess is the equipment no there's got
to be a per I don't know it was 5 Seconds that
was so fast yeah they go get military man and
give him a weapon come on daughter bro what is
going on she's old enough to have a gun and cover
the other side of the house come on that blonde
dude is he's a phenomenal phenomenal actor yeah
I can't believe I haven't seen him in much since
then maybe I have and he looks different he knows
how to play uh really offsetting very well also
all these other people in masks their agents
did not fight hard for their face to be seen
yeah oh my God untie him and ask him
to help you why did they not do that
makes me mad this family y'all aren't not
using your brains right I don't understand
this yeah that's stupid the
kid the little kid's going
to give him a gun I think what's two guns going to
do oh boy and skipping to it huh she doesn't
have a gun she has knives you brought knives to a
gunfight yeah man she's going to machete your head
off and probably have a lot of fun doing it is the
problem Oh behind her behind her behind her
behind you [__] behind you God you should
have un undone the military guy I don't know
why you're not asking for his help right now
and being in his little prep boy outfit I bet
he goes to school with the girl oh he probably
does right cuz the little uniforms yep I
cannot see what he is doing no I couldn't
even tell if it was him no some we're just
going to reach a person I was right and it
happened and I knew it oh my god did they get
the gun taken oh he's getting dragged I can't
see what's happening he's getting dragged this
movie is so dark okay dark emotionally but also
visually yes yes yes Dad all right
I mean of course he's going to check
under the bed kind of a go-to the little
lady s was sa for me oh that's some oh
gross gross [__] whoa what is
it that's a cool gun lawn mower
oh oh no oh no what is this oh they're
just like okay that's some gross freaky
[__]
wa this is a big weapon but I don't
feel like it has good aim okay come
on kill her his son needs to come
help yeah or the military guys got
to show up and kill him use the
come onuse your come on now all
right they're like animals disgusting
oh yeah go get that guy oh ah what is
he doing he's using a pool stick yeah I
guess where did what happened to his weapon
[Music] okay so sad to see that pinball game go
but had to be used can I tell you
something yep Ethan Hawk is hot
yeah always has been always will
be Y and now that he's less racist
and less classist in this movie he's he's way
better oh nice good job that's a great shot
who is it does he recognize her she's on like
a class if he goes to look at the other person
and makes that face I not see that coming your
soul has been cleansed Mr sandon you've purged
was this life really worth yours your families
thank you for this Unforgettable Purge
Mr sandon ew oh my God he should play
The Joker bro that's what I was going to
say him outside right now absolutely all
of his moves the laughing his face like
the whole thing what are the don't know
why are there still about to get killed
I don't know they're about to get killed
why oh it's the neighbors that she didn't
like it's the neighbors we didn't like they
came are they saving them like does
that make her a lot less shitty now
also where is the guy and why are
you guys not asking for his help
what don't hesitate why are you crazy
coming out of a wall like that just
screaming oh nope I don't like it I don't like
it we need the son or the daughter to show up
oh they want the military remember they want
to like sexually oh they're tickling her oh
it it might have been heard that they wanted
to save maybe not okay oh my [Music] God yes
oh the neighbors the neighbors no it's him
oh it's the neighbors yeah oh my God whoa
who are the ones who drove by in the car yes
and what they just leave they came to help
them I know but they weren't like hey are
you good like that was weird they're just
like I don't think they want to be seen I don't
know this is but why not because then you don't
support The Purge I don't know that seems like
a big thing here with the blue flowers Charlie
Charlie sorry how many hours into the purge
do you think we are well the sun's coming up
now that I'm realizing like the lighting here
oh no all you there in one place thank you for
your sacrifice you have a lot of heart Mr Sand
where's the daughter where rebor bed now the
daughter whoa get it girl she came out
from under the bed she's doing some
shooting at least she helps in some
way good job is he what's going on
cheit I bet the hospitals the next day are
just 5,000 hour weights oh he's gone yeah
y'all killed Ethan Hawk we saw that you were
having some trouble we decided to help you
she so what is going on there's a Twist here
thank you seem just I don't know what to say
don't thank us too much Mary you're going
to kill him the truth is you're our ours
not theirs what do you mean ours what do
you mean what do you mean ours what what
what maybe the boyfriend's still alive well
the military guy is going to going to come in
yeah yeah yeah forg I've been waiting on
him to kill six people in under a second
why you doing this yeah thank you why are
you doing this right now you made so much
money off of us and then you just stuck it
in our faces I'm really begging you right
now to not do this to my children this
is the first because ofon no be founding
fathers oh it's so freaking weird I'll go
first and then oh my God we'll take turns
okay come on buddy where is he oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah all right he he found the
remote
yes that's so satisy drop your weapons right
now and time let's go he could
have just saved himself but he
didn't kill them all your call your cough and kill
him just get it over with oh she's going to let
them live kill us quickly okay I guess you're
stepping up weirdo going to kill us it doesn't
matter we are going to play the rest of this
night out in [__] peace get out of my house what
okay so uncomfortable so
awkward what an interesting choice to end this
with oh my God you better no yes yes no
more killing tonight that hard to understand
nice now get the hell out of my house yeah I
was waiting for that line it's like now you
these are your neighbors right well you guys are
going to have to move like there are consequences
to everybody's actions no matter if there are
no consequences in that moment it's just like
something you gotta live with that I mean
that's why do I hope he stays and they get
married I know I'm sick something's wrong with
me please say thank you are you going to be okay
thank you good just after 7 a.m. March 22nd
the actual Purge has just concluded oo wow
the new founding fathers have released an early
statement saying this was the most successful
Purge yet what a creepy thing over these credits
voiceover literally I witness a group of young men
breaking into the T next to me and were bloody
stranger Edwin Hodge were killed last night for
their sacrifice to make this country a safer
place it's so weird this like rooms BR I was
wondering if they're going to be like oh what
do the emergency services do now do they just
clean up dead bodies anouncing in both sectors
profit it's it's weird they're talking about
profits in certain sectors and like how was the
most successful Purge it's all it's all a lot it
seems like Dallas had the most participants
Dallas for as long and there had to be 200
people in the Town Square purging at the same
time this is the first time I've ever listened
to credits before yeah me too I'm like I am so
curious this country is taking everything from
me interesting that's a good point it has to
turn people into like we support this purge
but then if you get if you get I guess purged out
you're going to be like I don't support this if if
literally everything is taken from you almost in
one night which is what I assume this this kind of
last comment was of like you can this whole night
you can be supportive of it but if it comes to you
a thing that like you think will never happen
you're like or your neighborhood tune might be
changing there was so many different twists and
turns and red herrings in this like you think
about the boyfriend at the beginning didn't end
up coming back or you think about when they let
in that stranger but he isn't the the downfall of
them although had they never opened their doors to
him he would have died but the family would have
lived um but you thought when he first let him
in I was super suspicious of him like oh he's
pretending to be hurt in the street to come in
me too but he wasn't they did a really good job
with all of that and then finally showing us we
think we know with all the rich kids and then it's
the neighbors your own neighbors who turn on you
who just brought you [__] cookies yeah that was
really it was it was every time I think I had it
I didn't have it yeah me neither that was really
good it was awesome I mean I loved the dialogue
the writing was great I mean as you said the story
is awesome but also her for Lena's I forget what
her character name is but for her like Dark Knight
of the Soul kind of mostly happened with her going
what are you doing what are we doing here and
it's it's almost that Ethan Hawk dying is like
that sucks right because he's just was trying to
be a good dad and a husband and keep his kids safe
but he never had that like Soul moment he just
was constantly going no let's just get him out
of here I don't care if we kill this guy um and
it was nice to see that they had written in for
Lena's character the mom character of her her
switch of like we can't do this he and oh he
did he was like we're going to fight you're right
uh his daughter his daughter looks at him and says
it will never be okay again look at what you're
doing it'll never be fine I think he did have it
that the moment to me the biggest foreshadowing is
when Ethan Hawk looks at the guy who came in and
said you're gonna die tonight one way or another
yeah either like a man walk out there and do it or
um they're going to come in and kill my kids too
and finally the guy says bring me out there and
that's when Ethan decides not to to fight because
I guess if you're going to go with your own logic
of be a man then you [__] be a man and fight
like you know and he does and then the not the
joke of it all but he's the one who ends up dead
not the guy he's the only one who ends up dead
in the family right yeah I feel like I guess the
the soul moment I I blanked for a moment that I
was like yeah he did get them all together and
be like we're going to fight is because Lena's
character really like spoke to it the most and
I really liked her saying that of like what are
we doing we can't do this and then her even
growing more into that especially at the end
of like there won't be any more killing like her
her making a choice for there to be peace for the
rest of the night even though these people were
ready to stab them her and all of her kids for
this purge nonsense that's crazy to me it's cool
generationally that we're wa when you're watching
this and the two kids like we just talked about
you just talked about the term of Ethan the turn
of Lena and the kids are the ones who are like
this is [__] wrong yeah the daughter and the
son and it's because you're not born with these
biases these prejudices these this evil you're not
born with that it it develops and it's a learned
behavior right it's a learned behavior to hate
people based on how much money they have the color
of their skin their age their size whatever the
[__] it is right and so the fact that we do
see them like that but then we're seeing that
the kids coming for the purge and her boyfriend
already have that hate in them that probably comes
from their parents right that probably comes from
their upbringing how they were raised whatever it
is yeah super [__] interesting to watch and to
see that the the kids are the ones that are are
able to get to their parents like or especially
their dad yeah that this is wrong it does set it
up where it's like the morally that family did
have it on on a right on the right spectrum of
like we have morals here but he was put in a tough
position when the when the guy initially came in
so I understand why he was doing that but I still
was upset that he didn't that the kid noticed like
I feel like the kid notic the tags like was
the first one that they wouldn't look at the
tags and be like why don't you just help us like
get out of this I I would have I would I mean he
did eventually but not really they didn't release
him he got out on his own and I would have really
liked to just see the family go we're not going
to sorry we I'm sorry I stabbed you a couple of
times and then tied you up but and then pushed on
it yeah like my God I was like I'd be like let's
try and tape this wound up and let's all try to
just survive the night together what do you think
the main message of the movie is if you had to
like put it into a sentence what do you think
the message is and which is so weird of me to ask
you after we just watched The Purge because I did
not think this was going to be a message oriented
movie like I thought it was going to be a horror
like Halloween or like Friday 13th or whatever I
did not think this was going to be as thematically
interesting as it was not that those other movies
aren't great but right I mean it's like the class
system sucks and they did a really nice job of
highlighting that the reasoning of the people at
the end of going they're not theirs you're ours
now and the reason we're killing you is because
you're flaunting your money in our face and yet
they all have an abundance of it it's like that's
what's getting to people in in the upper echelon
of society right it's like all right we're going
to purge you now because you you added an add-on
and we couldn't do that um it's so trivial it
makes it to where you're putting these uh the the
upper class Society into this like tiny little
box with these trivial little things and they
lose so much sight of what is right and what's
wrong and I mean we did luckily you know running
into Ethan and Lena their their family did have a
little bit of what's right and what's wrong in the
beginning they lost sight of it but we got them
back and that was good um so I don't I don't know
ex I think it's maybe just class system sucks and
there's a lot of trivial things when you when you
really look at it people have a lot of money lose
sight of what's I feel like actually important
CU like why why also was the kids that are like
this swine of a homeless person deserves to
be killed by us this is all just setting up
get out our anger yeah a class of system of like
you're not worthy and I'm like he fought for the
country that you live in now this is how all for
your freedom to do this exactly I think that the
the main message is not that you asked what do
you think per I think the main message is that
um no one person's life is more important than
another person's life right like no matter any
of the things and and this movie really hits that
home especially at the end with her not having him
[__] blast them um and I can't even lie at that
point I would I would said [__] well you said
blast him four times I think yeah because you guys
all were trying to kill us and at the end of the
day life is unbelievably important it matters
and we're only each given one and the when you
don't treat other people like their life matters
as much as yours because we were all lucky enough
to be born then you lose sight of everything if
you don't believe everybody around you's life is
as important as yours for whatever reason then
you're [__] yeah I agree and I mean I guess
that's like a another a huge thing that they they
highlight here that it does send a message that
there are real people like that that don't taken
it's just if you live in a crappy house in a poor
neighborhood you are less than than me and you
are not you're not living up to the standards of
what I deem to be a human if you're like a rich
person in this movie which is sad yeah what did
you think about the the combination of the way
that it was shot for the majority of the time
but then with like the camera I'm going to call
it ring cam obviously that's not what it was at
this time but just all and then the robot camera
did you like how we had a bunch of different kinds
of camera shots I feel like we did because the
the POV like the the handheld camera always felt
like it to me was in the POV of like what the
purge is now bringing like the POV of The Purge
coming up on you versus in the beginning setting
up the town we still had some Dolly and tracking
shots like smoother shots and uh uh and then just
yeah towards the end using the um when we saw the
people outside we really only saw them from the
security camera's point of view until they came
inside which I thought was a a fun way to do it
because we just we stayed in that POV of like
the house and what they're experiencing um and
I like that because they could have sure shown
shown them from the security footage and then cut
to actually them outside and what's going on and
where they're sitting what are they talking
about we didn't need it I like them utilizing
that footage of No Talking they're spread out you
just see them waiting around with their weapons it
kind of was a nice way to build up tension yeah I
completely agree and then also I feel like other
than the shots as two actresses here I think it'd
be crazy for us to not to talk a little bit about
these effing performances because as we were going
throughout it it's like no [__] Ethan Hawk and
Lena HEI are going to be yeah them great I mean
they were phenomenal but then their two kids
really nailed it the guy who comes into the house
who we are immediately suspicious of that's all
in his eyes and the dude fire I was just like wow
each one of you guys I I wonder what this casting
process was like because obviously I'm assuming
that Ethan and Lena well actually what year was
this that that I'm thinking Lena got offer so yeah
that would have been in the height of probably
Game of Thrones time right a little bit still I
think so so I would say no mudy little bit it's
the beginning yeah yeah the beginning yeah
2013 so I would say that probably Ethan gets
this straight offer maybe she auditioned but she
must have smoked everybody cuz she was so good and
these other people were did you know them at all
like they're unknowns to not at all for them to
like be at Ethan's caliber I was like wow that's
really impressive yeah I thought the only weird
Choice which I also liked it was the neighbor the
blonde annoying lady that it was like she was so
robotic but I know it was a choice of like she's
weird there's something off here um yeah yeah but
then you know what was interesting I'm so with you
that that was weird but when she comes at the end
because of her choices I thought I'm being such a
dick judging a book by its cover in terms of like
she was this white blonde girl who shows up with
cookies and already I'm like [__] creepy and I
was like why Rox like we just learned don't judge
a book by its cover she's come to save them be on
her side and then it was like nope [__] we're
flipping again yeah oh God it it was so great
when especially when you see the two neighbors I
was like there's still something weird here where
they shoot the people off and they don't ask Lena
if she's okay they just like move on and I'm like
this is something weird is going on here uh but
yeah I like the setup that initially we we felt
like something was a little off-kilter with her
and then especially at the end the way she spoke
it's like you're going to Stepford wi land very
satisfying to see her nose get bashed that that
was so great and to see Lena do that herself she'd
need her backup right is so great and he just and
and I agree with um the casting for him which I I
mean he didn't have a name military guys is what
I kept calling him is that um what do they call
him the credit stranger something I don't know
bloody stranger I think they called him think
oh boy well I'm going to look up on IMDb what
actually his his thing is yeah yeah I feel like
in his eyes but especially just like him you could
just feel he had a heart and like uh he he had a
right versus wrong and he felt very defeated um
in the beginning he was fighting for his life
which yeah I I would too listen I'm not going
to die tonight I'm not here to hurt you guys but
please don't send me out there um okay so Edwin
Hodge played bloody stranger that is his name in
his bloody Str oh and he's from Mayan's the Kurt
Suter show after uh Sons of Anarchy he's been
in a lot of different stuff his his whole vibe
in this movie of saying everything without saying
a word really good stuff really good uh wow a lot
of these people work a ton so yeah and then that
guy Rees Wakefield is the blonde dude dude he was
so effing creepy oh and he shares a birthday
with my mom oh he was on True Detective oh I
love that show all right well I'm going to look
more into them you ever see somebody that you're
like wow you're very good and then you you star
them or heart them on you favorite them on IMDb
and you just like start watching their work like
that this oh totally and then you look you're
like oh they've been working all of their lives
they're like they've been working since they were
four yeah all right damn it's amazing and that's
gonna be us one day until then The Purge any other
final baby I would rate I I mean this movie to me
I I'm I'll give it like an 8.5 I really I really I
really enjoyed it and and it was short and sweet
not sweet short short and good yeah really good
grounded well done performances and the writing
the story I love the writing the writing and the
story really great the only thing that made me
mad is that they didn't untie military guy and
ask him to fight along with him but it it added
for a Twist at the end where he pops up but I was
yeah and there was a lot of popups at the end but
I liked every one of them horror often times has
[__] dialogue I've noticed that it feels forced
and weird this didn't it felt like the characters
were developed uh even if you didn't like them at
times it was like yeah that is a brat teenage girl
that's what they're like bro exactly I've been
there and I was like oh she's so annoying and
then I was like oh actually see myself in her what
a bummer uh okay so That's The Purge and I'm going
to be brainstorming what I would Purge until the
next time is there a sequel to this I don't know
you would think so right as a premise you could
do this over and over and over again right I would
be interested to see if they choose to just follow
one family or now choose to follow multiple people
along the course of a Purge Night imagine being
a shop owner no I would I would uh just lock it
up and go yeah this year I have my I have my shop
for a good 8 n 10 months cuz it's going to take me
3 months to rebuild and then every year I got to
start over again cuz the purge is coming it's just
like a diamond store like you just can't take
your diamonds home put them in your pockets or
saer in your pockets shove them up my Cooter and
be like well they got to come for me before they
get the diamonds you heard it here first guys and
gals and people at home Tara's going to shove the
diamonds up her cter on that note thank you like
comment subscribe give us all that love we'll
Purge with you later later with all the diamonds
that got in our bloodstream okay bye [Music] bye